this Spring Track Meet in Kelowna BC
took an unexpected and horrible turn
when the gender of a nine-year-old girl
taking part in a shot put event was
questioned in an anti-trans attack
according to her mother who watched it
all unfold all of a sudden there was
this yelling of
um
well I didn't hear what Heidi heard at
first but then get that boy off the
field sort of thing
and then it took a minute to realize
that they were talking about our
daughter Carrie Starr says her daughter
whose identity is being protected always
had long hair and recently decided to
cut it shorter because it made playing
sports easier our daughter was crying
and consolably because he's just
continuing to Badger her but he wouldn't
let it go this gentleman wouldn't let it
go
kept badgering and yelling demanding
certification of her being female the
school district superintendent told
Global News its own investigation found
a couple was being belligerent and
intimidating to the point where the
sporting event had to be moved to a
different location and the couple who
was there to support a grandchild from
another school district didn't leave as
directed The offenders here are going to
be banned from all future
school events and school properties
because they're clearly not safe around
children our human rights laws are very
clear you can't discriminate on the
basis of gender identity or or gender
expression Dr Elizabeth sawick heads a
research center focused on stigma and
youth trans and non-binary young people
are less likely to participate in sports
half as likely girls
of any background are also less likely
to stay in sports
she says misinformation about trans
issues is fueling bigotry at a growing
rate a protest in Ottawa Friday
organized by a group against what they
call gender ideology was met with
hundreds of counter protesters
local police say they're investigating
the incident but not as a hate crime all
the girls in that event were
flabbergasted like shocked as support
continues to pour in for the girl after
an incident the family says has left
many reeling Global News Vancouver